Rainbow six siege is open peter was
supposed to go live yesterday but it
didn't cutting it a little fine for the
game's launch on December first but as
long as angela bassett still in it I'll
survive I'm Lucy and welcome to this
delayed gamespot news update so the open
beta for Rainbow six siege was supposed
to begin yesterday November 25th at ten
a.m. EST however give us up run into
some issues and has made the decision to
postpone the beta on xbox one ps4 and PC
an update on the games forums reads
we're currently seeing issues with
matchmaking times and disconnection on
all platforms as such we're postponing
the open beta until a later time and
keeping the game under closed beta
status we apologize for the delay and
can assure you this is our top priority
we will keep everyone updated regularly
as we continue to deploy improvements
updating proven ight community manager
ub underscore jax revealed that they'd
uncovered the root issue and that a fix
was being tested and reassured fans that
the open beta is in fact intended to
find and troubleshoot such issues before
release to ensure a stable launch you
were soft also keen to say that they are
confident that the launch of rainbow
succeed will not be impacted by this
issue meanwhile the games closed beta
continues and Ubisoft will be updating
fans on their official forums as to when
they can expect the open beta so are you
get to play rainbow 6 siege tell me how
you pronounce the word betta in the
comments section below i'm on twitter at
Lucy James games and for the latest on
Rainbow six siege keeping gamespot